for generations this peaceful island has  been home to our family but beyond our  ease a great danger is coming  majan tells of a hero who journey to  find the demigod Maui  and together they will save us all  no LOL  Maui semi god of the wind and key I  heroic men what it's actually Maui  shapeshifter demigod of the women see  hero of men I interrupt it from the top  hero of men go impact going on a mission  with some little girls is my canoe and  you will journey to different did not  see that coming the ocean is a friend of  mine  first we've got to go through a whole  ocean a bad Kaka hora kako what they're  kind of cute  the body  I got your back it's Mary time  Oh  really blow dart and my butt cheek we're  going to the realm of monsters don't  worry it's a lot farther down than it  looks  you